hi there steve kaufman here
again to talk about language learning
and i'm going to
focus today on compelling input ci
which i consider to be
a revolution in language learning a
revolution not because
it's totally new in the sense that i
think that's always how people have
learned languages but it's a revolution
in the sense that
language instruction language teachers
are increasingly recognizing that we
learn the language through input
hopefully compelling input
and that a lot of the
specific sort of language instruction
testing
grammar explanation is
rather
is significantly less important
that the time we spend on that
activity is usually better spent
with compelling input
now in that regard
tomorrow i'm going to portland oregon or
near portland oregon where stephen
krashen and benico mason
are running a clinic on story listening
they have these clinics uh in various
places in the united states perhaps
elsewhere
and they work with teachers
and explain and talk about different
techniques for
using story listening
as the sort of core
instructional technique
as opposed to
explanations drills and testing
i don't know much more about it than
that i will know much more after
tomorrow
but
it's people like particularly stephen
krashen and beniko mason who are the
revolutionaries who have introduced this
simple concept of compelling input and i
know that in my own case i have used
compelling input to learn languages if
you look behind me you see books
and you know cds and stuff and i have
immersed myself in all kinds of
compelling input in order to learn
languages and have spent relatively
little time on
grammar explanations it doesn't mean i
have spent no time on grammar
explanations i do review them the
grammar rules with no intention of
remembering what i see
i review you know declension tables with
no intention of remembering what i see
there but i do find that it helps to
make me
a little more alert
helps me to get more out of my input
activities
and apparently there's a story that abe
lincoln said if i were going to cut down
a tree i would spend 80 percent of my
time sharpening the axe so some of these
materials some of these activities
rather
can help you make can help make you more
alert more observant i notice in my
arabic for example after each lesson i
go through the words and phrases in fact
i deliberately say certain phrases and
then i review them using a dictation so
i'm forced to write out in arabic what i
hear
i this does slow me down in terms of
acquiring new words but on the other
hand it helps me read better because
with arabic a major problem is the
writing system i'm still confusing
letters uh arabic letters and so forth
and so on
so compelling input one other thing with
regard to input i just did a 27-minute
interview with oli richards who is a
great
polyglot and has a following and i'm
going to put links to his blog and his
website here
and oli has produced graded readers
in a variety of languages and oli who
speaks who is fluent in a lot of
languages including three romance
languages has decided to
spend two to three months focusing on
italian very much input-based and he's
going to keep a record of his activities
and progress he's going to do this with
the link and we talk about this in a
video and the video will be put up on
this channel on thursday
so while i mention oli and i mentioned
graded readers i want to touch a bit on
the subject of compelling input now
tomorrow or the following day
when i meet with stephen krashen and and
benico mason and others
we will talk about compelling input one
issue with compelling input is when you
start in a language and people often ask
me how do you start listening how do you
start reading you don't know anything
obviously you have to start with simple
material you have to start with simple
material where you have both audio and
text
i do this of course using link because
then i can look words up and i can
review them and and then listen and if i
you know create playlists of my lessons
then the playlists track how many hours
i'm listening and so there are a lot of
statistics there that remind me that i
am progressing in the language even
though at times i feel frustrated that i
think i'm not making any great progress
so there is i think there are three
stages of
input
the first stage is these simple
materials like our many stories which
are not that simple but
i think they're accessible for most
people at a very early stage if not the
absolute beginner stage i'm using them
as a beginner in arabic
that that this is material that is not
authentic
it's not tremendously compelling it
talks about everyday situations in life
uses you know high frequency verbs and
there's a lot of repetition but because
we are struggling to get a toehold on
the language and we're struggling to
notice and remember words and phrases to
that extent it's compelling i find
because i am motivated to learn the
language but very soon you want to move
into something where the actual content
is of itself interesting
so oli for example has these graded
readers
people may invent stories children's
stories the difficulty there is that
people's interests vary like i would be
interested in a graded reader for
example in arabic on arabic history i'm
not so interested in a graded reader
taken from a thousand and one nights for
example i just i'm less interested in
that i would be interested in
sort of relatively easy conversation
natural conversation which is then
transcribed because natural conversation
tends to use
more high frequency words so all of
those things would be the kind of graded
material that i'm interested in other
people might be interested in children's
stories folk tales or whatever so we
have the the beginner material with a
lot of repetition we have graded
material which it's a little more
difficult to find something that suits a
wide variety of tastes and then we have
the sort of genuine authentic material
and there we can find it on the internet
and audio for example il naratore who
produces wonderful italian uh ebooks
naratorepuntocom.com and he puts out
audio ebooks so you can take the ebook
import it into link listen to the audio
so
to me i see compelling input as
consisting of the beginner material a
lot of repetition
intermediate material which is
lower sort of or more higher percentage
of high frequency vocabulary and then
the genuinely authentic compelling input
so i'm very interested in finding out
with these teachers in portland and
stephen krashen and beniko mason how
they deal with these sort of stages of
compelling input because compelling has
also to be comprehensible
uh
one final point here i'm interested in
meeting with teachers
and
we at link we want to get more involved
with groups like a classroom group or
other groups how do you
adapt link
to a classroom situation or to some
other group learning situation what are
the tasks that you assign your learners
uh
that they bring to the classroom or to
the group discussion and and what do
they do then in the classroom and how
does that relate to their
uh link learning activity
and uh we have one uh person in spain
antonio who is working with us to try to
uh
make more schools universities and other
groups in spain aware of link and how it
can be tremendously beneficial to their
language learning
part of it is to explain the power of
compelling input i mean links as link is
is a facilitator
a system that makes compelling input
more accessible more quickly and helps
you retain vocabulary
so antonio
has asked me asked me to do a video
introducing link and i did this in
spanish and so after this video you'll
be able to listen to uh my video in
spanish i apologize there are no
subtitles
we also have a collaborator constantine
who is in kiev and who is an online
tutor to russian speakers wherever they
might be located
he went to bratislava to the polyglot
conference and spoke about how he uses
link in his online tutoring
activity but he is also looking at ways
in ukraine where he lives and perhaps
elsewhere in the russian speaking world
to
look at how link can be used as part of
a group or classroom based learning
experience so those are kinds of the the
kind of the directions that we are
heading into
and so if you understand spanish you can
listen to my spanish video
and thursday you'll hear my discussion
with oli and we will have an opportunity
to follow
all his progress
alright then thank you for listening bye
for now
[Music]
you